j'ai fait mon premier poulet basquaise à
4 ans mon premier souffle et a5 ma
puissance culinaire ils sont limite tu
sais mon gars ici c'est un restaurant
routier alors on fait surtout du steak
frites des saucisses frites et de
l'andouillette frites on peut pas
présenter chars la carte du printemps
j'ai pu quitter comme on attend c'est le
quatrième restaurant qui devient ce mois
ci ils comprennent rien à ce que je fais
incroyable y réfléchir tu vois le pâtre
là bas le peintre demain à 8h au cargö
il est en retard
louis 8h12 c'est bien ce que je dis vous
êtes en retard et on va où là sur le
plateau télé on va faire mon émission
c'est quand même bien meilleurs sons de
ciboulette mi-temps à ta gueule la
création ici c'est moi howard lagarde
si tu perds une étoile ton contrat il
saute je suis cuit je sais je connais
quelqu'un côté marotte de machu
continuèrent manière
cyril boss pourquoi je conduirai pas
manger dans son restaurant tout le monde
connaît caniche noir jours
spaghettis au rythme j'ai fait un
rapprochement entre un plat d'alexandre
d'aujourd'hui une sauce d'alexandre
d'hier oui mais alexandre vous dit de ne
plus faire de rapprochement ou entre
alexandre et alexandre et je sais quand
même comment alexandre travail mais
l'élection de ces bois et alors je vois
pas le rapport
[Musique]